what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
[Music]
alright I will preface this by saying
that at some point along the line I may
cover awesome I'm really not sure yet I
mean I'm not really sure if I really
want to like cover that story in its
entirety and this video will tell you
why because the onslaught saga is like
the biggest event had never happened
like nothing happened in this I mean
stuff happen but there was it was it was
just an excuse from over to reboot stuff
but anyway welcome to the rundown guys
this is my series where I'm like hey
here is a thing I enjoyed and you guys
should enjoy it too now before we get
into this a bit of explanation so in the
late 80s to mid 90s marvel's landscape
was a mess it was messier than my room
when I was 15 years old and I know some
of you guys are looking around the room
right now like yeah man
my rooms pretty messy but um but Marvel
had plot threads everywhere I mean there
were stories that chris claremont had
left hanging and he just never wrapped
up because he left like five issues into
x-men vol 2 I mean it was just stuff
everywhere it was it was absolutely
insane and so by this point Scott Lowe
Dale had taken over the title but there
are two characters that we need to worry
about the first is Nate gray and the
second is Bishop now Nate gray came out
of a story called the Age of Apocalypse
and this is basically a story where
Charles Xavier son Legion had traveled
into the past under the belief that if
he killed magneto it would make life
easier for Charles Xavier the issue with
this is that Charles Xavier jumped in
the way he died the villain apocalypse
said time to go and he took over the
world or took over North America anyway
but during the whole Age of Apocalypse
event the villain mr. sinister who had
always been obsessed with you know the a
child of Jean Grey and Scott Summers or
I guess Jean Grey Cyclops that was
always his thing uh he had basically
used their genes to create a kid named
x-man Nate gray and the idea was that
Nate grey was going to defeat apocalypse
and his incredible powers we're going to
be used by mr. sinister so that he could
take over the world the problem with
this is that magneto beat mr. sinister
to the punch he tore apocalypse
half he set his plans in motion and then
everything returned to normal it was
weird
1990s comics it was it was weird it was
strange but what this did is it allowed
Nate gray to basically emerge into the
main Marvel Universe and the reason why
is because he was insanely popular when
he first showed up people were just like
dude this guy who's basically limitless
in his abilities he can do everything
but warp reality like he's really really
powerful and fans absolutely loved it
because in the 1990s was all about
high-octane super fast stuff so anyway
so Nate gray is just kind of hanging out
in the main Marvel Universe now the
other guy is Bishop Bishop comes from a
universe that's almost exactly like the
Days of Future past I mean like
identical some event happened in his
timeline it initiated the start of the
Sentinel program the Sentinels started
rounding up mutants and people with
superpowers eventually killed off a
majority of them the rest were just kind
of thrown in internment camps eventually
the signals turned their sights on
humanity they started imprisoning
humanity the difference between the Days
of Future past and bishops timeline is a
Tim bishops timeline there was an event
called the Summers rebellion and that
was where humans and mutants work
together to cast off the Sentinels the
problem with this was that there was
this weird uneasy truce but bishops
whole gig was that he traveled to the
modern day to find out who the traitor
was that initiated the event that caused
his han line to come to fruition and the
idea was that mom was always toying
around with it well maybe this time
we'll find out who the traitor is maybe
this time we'll find out who it is the
problem was that this has been going on
for damn near ten years and people just
stopped caring so they were like
whatever he's just a guy here people
shoot him with energy and he projects it
back whatever the the harmonica song
from Bishop in x-men the animated series
I will do the the future I will do that
at some point along the line but that
basically kind of brings us to brings us
to onslaught now with regards to the
character of onslaught the way to work
like this the whole story had its roots
and a story called fatal attractions
because Scott lowdown had taken over the
title Marvel was looking around it was
the middle of the comic bus like comics
sales were at an all-time low
Marvel was like okay DC is owned by
Warner Brothers they have corporate
backing they'll never go broke we do not
have corporate backing no one is
financing us so if we don't make how
much that sell then we're just gonna go
broke and that's gonna be the end of
Marvel so what they said was we are
going to basically eliminate everything
that's not selling so they looked around
they said okay what's not selling right
now everything but the x-men
literally everything but the x-men was
doing bad everything the Incredible Hulk
the Avengers Fantastic Four Iron Man's
force work steam the whole nine yards it
was who was all doing absolutely
terrible some are most said okay fine we
don't do hard we don't do line wide
reboots like crisis on Infinite Earths
we're just gonna do like a soft reboot
we're basically gonna kill them off and
then reimagine them enter the onslaught
saga so fatal attractions rolls around
and basically it's magneto being a dick
he's just like you know what I'm just
gonna be mean and I'm just gonna go to
all the mutants and all I kind of some
and say hey if you want to join me on
asteroid M then you can come there
because I'm gonna I'm just gonna like
have my own base of operations this led
to humanity freaking out believing
magneto was going to attack them because
his base of operations is basically
equipped with nuclear missiles and so
magneto issued an EMP across the world
took out power to everything the x-men
responded they went to Magneto's base of
operations magneto is like you know what
I'm tired of you guys being here
you're becoming a pain in the ass like
here's what I'm gonna do to you guys if
you keep it up he rips the adamantium
out of Wolverines body one of the
greatest moments in the history of
comics like it'd be worth covering fatal
attractions just to cover the story
where adamantium gets his oar Wolverine
gets his adamantium worked out
adamantium gets his Wolverine ripped out
it would be worth it just to cover that
because of such a great story but uh
Charles Xavier was watching what's going
on he's like dude are you serious man
that's not cool so he shuts down the
mind of magneto now what this did is it
allowed Marvel to basically go forward
reinvent magneto as a character named
Joseph and he had no idea about his past
it was basically rebooting it like a
soft reboot for his character now for
however long something like 20 issues or
something along those lines ah nothing
ever came out of fatal attraction so
which is like hey Wolverine got his
adamantium ripped out now we just ran
into the woods and he's savage Wolverine
or whatever it is you know animalistic
Wolverine didn't have a nose so it was
just like that weird thing going on but
eventually we found out that what had
happened was when Xavier shut down the
mind of Magneto he didn't just like
strip him of his identity in his
memories he absorbed Magneto's
consciousness like his memories all I
kind of good stuff
and so magneto hatred for humanity
blended with Charles Xavier frustration
with humanity over the fact that mutants
just would not or just could not get
along with humans because humans were
just being dicks and so eventually this
these two front renewal forms of
irritation and frustration mingled with
one another and the onslaught entity was
born now the first thing it does is
race law races off - this whole signal
production plan and it just like takes
over the programming of the Sentinels
and then doesn't do anything with them
for like a long time then it goes to
Jean Grey and it's like hey Jean Grey uh
let's go hang out because like she's in
the middle of like changing clothes and
so like he takes her consciousness or
whatever it is like their telepathic
powers allow them to go out into the
world or whatever you know an onslaught
it's like hey you know xavier x' dream a
peaceful coexistence right and she's
like yeah and he's like that's never
gonna happen and here's why and he just
takes her on this on this tour of like
mutants that are being killed by humans
and humans who were just being dicks you
know he's like that's why because people
are just terrible and they're never
going to accept you you know and Jean
Grey's like know I believe in Xavier
stream Xavier is a good guy I believe in
his dream and on slots like oh really so
like he shows her this old repressed
memory that Xavier had where she was
hanging around something like that and
Charles is like man I really wish Jean
Grey loved me because I love her and
Jean Grey is like really like Charles
Xavier loves me that's so weird you know
and so she's like no I still believe him
I I still believe in this whole thing
alright so she's got like the word
onslaught branded on her head because
he's like know my name cuz he's like who
are you she has no idea who he is so
it's weird it's like this psychic bruh
it's literally like a blue psychic brand
of his name on her forehead now while
all this is going on like beast and
Bishop are just hanging out at some
place they're coming out of some movie
or something I've had on them roughed up
my head but then like the juggernaut
just crash lands and people are just
like what in the hell is the juggernaut
like who knocked the juggernaut over
here and juggernauts like I got knocked
halfway across the country by some guy
named onslaught now ocelots next act is
to basically like up here before the
x-men cuz on slots plan is like okay my
original idea was to hit up Jean Grey
because she's like the Phoenix she's
like really powerful but she didn't want
to sorry well she's not really the
Phoenix now but it's like she didn't
want to side with me you know and so
he's like okay fine then what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna go to the X min so he
breeze all the x-men together alright at
this point he's still like you know in
the form of Xavier but he brings all the
x-men together and he's like hey x-men
and they're like what's up man and he's
like you want to go kill people and the
expert nope because we don't do that
Charles Xavier we don't know what your
problem is man if you're just off your
rocker you haven't had enough sleep or
you haven't had your afternoon nap we do
not kill people that's not cool and so
I'm sloths like okay fine you know what
whatever so like he just unleashes
himself and the axmen are just like well
man that's weird but he just turned into
this guy that's
like a half Magneto half Xavier like
that's crazy and so like while that
happens like they go down and sort of
looking through his files and stuff you
know whatever and they're like why does
why does like Charles Xavier have like
you know like database files on Franklin
Richards and if somebody's like well
because he's like he's that son of like
you know Reed Richards a Susan storm
like he could warp reality and then
there's all like oh my god so at this
point onslaught has like Charles Xavier
trapped inside of his body alright he
takes off over to the Fantastic Four he
appears as like a little boy like he
starts talking to Franklin Richards you
know in Franklin's like hey you seem
really nice so like let's hang out you
know it's like they're playing games
doing whatever it is they do and then
like onslaught gets into the
subconscious mind of a Franklin Richards
takes over his mind takes him hostage
and then like absorbs him alright the
next step is he goes and he finds x-men
Nate grey he's like you're coming with
me and he absorbs him too and so the
idea of onslaught is to basically like
use Franklin Richards to remake the
earth like to remake existence as he
wants to use Nate gray to turn the
entirety of humanity into like a
collective consciousness for some weird
thing like that basically like make
humans subservient to his will and the
best way to start doing this is to make
a citadel in Central Park New York and
so like the first battle like these like
the Fantastic Four freaking out because
like some crazy guy that looks like
magneto and Xavier stole their son the
x-men of the Avengers are like guys we
got to do something man because like
this dude's dangerous and so like they
go they they all go to fight onslaught
right so they're like onslaught we're
here to stop you do they get their asses
kicked like right off the bat he's just
like peace I mean they rescue Charles
Xavier but then that's it and then
Charles Xavier is like dude why did you
guys take me out of onslaught and
they're like what are you talking about
we're here to rescue you then he's like
no like I was the one thing keeping him
in check the one thing they kept him
from just laying waste to existence and
now he's just gonna do whatever he wants
and onslaughts like yep this was all the
trap the only reason why I even let you
get this close was because I wanted you
to be able to take Charles Xavier atomy
so that I would have his powers and I
would be able to be like not controlled
by him and so at this point onslaught
has like all the powers of Charles
Xavier
he's got the powers of Franklin Richards
he's got the powers of x-men Nate grey
alright during this whole conflict like
we end up handing over and like The
Watcher is talking to apocalypse right
and the watch of the watch was like dude
apocalypse man you might want to get
involved and apocalypse is like no
survival of the fittest if they're too
weak to survive against onslaught then
that's their problem and the Watchers
like yeah man but like he's gonna remake
reality man and that means that you're
probably gonna die he's like upon
further consideration I have decided to
become involved in this conflict so it's
like The Avengers the Fantastic Four
onslaught Doctor Doom is there like
magneto is Joseph now is there I mean
it's like everyone who's anyone it's
like the biggest party ever like they're
all down there in Central Park and like
they're all fighting onslaught and
they're all getting like totally wrecked
I mean they're getting absolutely
obliterated
so finally apocalypse shows up on the
battlefield right like Susan storm cable
like all these guys are like hey we need
to like go into onslaught we need to
find a way to like save Franklin
Richards because if he possesses
Franklin he can legitimately warp
reality if he can figure out how to get
Franklin to use his powers cuz onslaught
can't like use Franklin's powers yes to
get Franklin to use his powers and so
because of this like apocalypse shows up
and cables like I'm gonna kill you and
like just immediately attacks him like
right off the bat he just starts
attacking that a lot of them cuz
remember like apocalypse rules the
future in cables timeline so cables like
I'm always on a mission to kill
apocalypse as soon as I see em I attack
MPO and Susan storms like guys you gotta
break it up you got to stop fighting
alright you guys gotta stop fighting you
guys got to be cool man like it's a
party be cool so what is I'm happening
as apocalypse is like hey I can help you
guys get inside of onslaught you know
and everybody's like no no no because if
you go in there you're gonna like try to
capture
Franklin Richards or you're gonna try to
like kill Franklin Richards or something
stupid like that apocalypse is like no
is this the face of a man who would lie
to you and so because of that like
they're like ok yeah you would lie your
ass off but we do kind of need your help
because you're like the oldest mutant
ever Selene is not a mutant and we need
your help to pull this off so they go
into onslaught and Susan's like hey I'm
just gonna stay out here and chill you
know whatever I'm just gonna hang out as
Hardy cuz everybody's having a really
good time I don't want to leave I saw
like cable goes in there and apocalypse
goes in there and like as soon as they
find Franklin's sure enough apocalypse
is like and now you die and Susan's like
nope I was here the entire time Oh see
how clever I am and so they grab
apocalypse and they're like we got to
get out of here because we got to find a
different way to try to say Franklin
whatever so they end up leaving alright
by this point like on slots forces of
the signals are just like wreaking havoc
marvel's got to give spider-man
something to do so like the Green Goblin
decides it now's a good time to attack
quite a man and so on and so forth so
he's fighting him and trying to save
people all the same time this is not
Peter Park
by the way but what is up happening is
gene grades like hey guys I have a
genius idea
and like okay what's your idea Jean Grey
she's like how about we like suppress
the Bruce Banner persona in The
Incredible Hulk and then have him go
against onslaught everybody's like man I
don't know about that and she's like
wise it's like well because it's the
Incredible Hulk what makes you think he
won't attack us and Jean Grey is like
well you have to have faith you have to
have faith in what's gonna happen so
like she suppresses the the Bruce Banner
persona of the Incredible Hulk so now
it's just like rage The Incredible Hulk
runs up on onslaught punches the hell
out of him cracks his armor right and so
on slots like how did you do that and so
now he's just like energy all right
everybody's like yay we damaged him we
successfully hit him once and so because
of that
Thor's is just like dives into onslaught
and people are just like what the hell
but he just jumped in onslaught you know
authority a man you know he just jumps
in and so everybody else is like well
hey I guess it's the only way to beat
him so like they all start jumping in
like the Avengers the Fantastic Four are
jumping in the x-men go to jump in and
everybody's like now this is this you
guys aren't allowed in this party this
is this is not an x-men party the truth
is that it was believed that if
onslaught were to take possession of a
mutant who would make him virtually
unstoppable it was just a reason for why
Marvel didn't need to reboot the x-men
because they were selling well why would
you change what sells well and so
because of that it allowed Marvel to
basically kill off quote-unquote the
Fantastic Four the Avengers I am and so
on and so forth for reboot them we
launched them as part of the heroes
reborn story onslaught dissipates and
the day is saved
meanwhile Franklin Richards is walking
around with a little blue ball which is
actually the heroes reborn universe that
he created because he's got godlike
powers that goes into heroes reborn
which eventually leads into heroes
return and then so on and so forth
anyway yes ah so the onslaught saga is
like the biggest event had ever happened
like it was cool well it wasn't it was
cool like Sal and I had had a
conversation about this the story was
cool when we were like 15 years old it
was a coolest thing in the world in
hindsight with like Civil War and house
of a man like the fifty thousand other
stories that have happened between
onslaught and now it's not that cool but
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you hit the subscribe button to become
part of the robb core make sure you drop
a like and uh yeah I will catch you all
later
[Music]